welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is JD Quinn it's my pleasure to be able
to spend this time with you the truth of
the matter is you can be doing anything
you want to do right now but you've
chosen because 3abn question and answer
is important because these are questions
that we all search for at some time or
the other and I am just so happy that we
got three intellectuals here that are
students of the Bible and they get in
and uh I just know from uh experience
that it takes a long time to answer
these questions especially within the
time uh given but let me introduce you
to each one we got uh via Skype from
California James rafy Pastor James raffy
how are you doing
James doing really good JD it's so good
to be here with you via Skype and uh
it's a blessing to be part of a program
that helps people to get answers to
their questions from the Bible amen amen
and Daniel parin how are you doing today
Daniel I'm doing great happy to be here
good to be here with these good people
amen and the Beautiful Shelley Quinn how
are you doing Shelley Quinn you can tell
that he's a little biased we want to
thank you so much for your questions
because this gives us an opportunity to
reexamine the things we believe we know
and we love to do this program we're
glad to be here amen amen
well those that have a question and that
wants the answers the way to contact us
is very simple you if you want to do it
by text you can text it 618
3975 once again
618 228
3975 if you'd like to contact us by
email it's Bible QA 3abn.org
V once again Bible QA
3abn.org
today thank you Lord for life itself
thank you Lord that you're on our mind
and father very thank you so much Lord
that you're the one that's in charge we
just ask Lord that we have ears to hear
hear your voice Lord and the eyes to see
as we keep our eyes focused on you be
with this program Lord let the answers
flow freely we give you praise and glory
in the name of Jesus amen amen amen
James we're going to start with you okay
yes sir number one question if you're no
longer working and only drawing Social
Security and your spouse's pension do
you still pay tithe out of that and this
is from Cheryl in
Kentucky thank you cheryln Kentucky for
that great question you know if you've
always paid tithe and offering on your
gross income then when you begin
receiving your Social Security you've
prepaid your tithe and offering this is
because Social Security is simply paying
you back the money that you have already
paid in and if you've already paid tithe
and offering on that money you've always
paid your tithe and offering offing on
your gross income then you've already
got your tithe and offering covered now
you just need to figure out how much you
paid into Social Security over the years
you've worked and that's pretty pretty
easy because Social Security they give
you a summary of your years worked and
how much you've actually paid in and
then you know how much you've already
paid in on ties and offerings once you
pass that amount of course that you've
paid in on Social Security uh then um
you start receiving monies that you
haven't paid tithe and offering on and
that would be your increase you pay an
offering on your increase you return
your tithe of course it's the Lord's and
then you pay or give offering beyond
that now for example if I paid in so
social security for 40 years and I have
a total of let's say $100,000 I paid
into Social Security and I've always
paid tithe than offering on my gross
income uh then I've already paid tith an
offering on that $100,000 once I start
receiving beyond the $100,000 when I
live to be 90 95 100 years old the Lord
hasn't come yet um then I would start
paying money after the 100,000 I've
already paid tithe in offering on uh by
paying on my gross income I would start
paying tithe on that extra in Christ now
having said that if you're up for a
financial challenge giving more to God's
cause is always an option we can never
outgive God but it is fun trying the
blessing that we have been given is in
Malachi 31-12 bring all the tithes into
the storehouse that there may be meet in
my house and prove me now here with
sayith the Lord of hosts that I will not
pour out open up the windows of heaven
and pour out a blessing that there shall
not be room enough for you to receive it
and I I will destroy uh rebuke the
devour for your sakes that he not
destroy the fruits of your ground that's
what Malachi 3 says and then uh it says
all nations shall call you blessed so
again we can never out give God but it
is fun trying and of course the very
best thing that we can do with the money
that God gives us even if we pay tithe
and offering on if we can is to invest
in his work on Earth uh Social Security
is an investment of sorts we invested
into the government and we get benefits
back from the government in time you
know we don't get that much if you
really think about it uh due to
inflation Etc but the investment we make
in God's kingdom is fourfold greater
than the investment we make in Social
Security why well number one it supports
pastors and evangelists right and number
two of course through supporting pastor
and evangelist it wins Souls uh to
heaven for all eternity uh number three
it brings God's blessings to us both
temporal and spiritual blessings and
then number four it actually helps
remove selfishness from our hearts so
giving sacrificially the woman's the
widows might uh it's a blessing for us
it's a blessing for others now the same
would apply to a pension uh if you have
paid into a pension plan and you're
receiving income from a pension plan or
you're receiving your spouse's income
from that pension plan and you've paid
your tithe and offering uh Faithfully on
your gross income that would include the
money you've given into that pension
plan and so of course you've already
covered it but you may uh reap benefits
beyond what you put in that Pension Plan
many people do and of course we want to
uh take up God's challenge and we want
to see if we can outgive him which we
can't but it's fun trying and we want to
give as much as we can to God's cause
because we know it supports his workers
it brings souls to the kingdom of heaven
it brings blessings to us and it helps
remove selfishness from our hearts amen
very well stated James very well stated
Daniel your first question what do the
many Bible references talking about the
right position and the right hand mean
for example Christ was sitting at the
right side of God he had seven stars in
his right hand God says he will uphold
us with his right hand Etc and this is
from Ben and morus that's an East Africa
all right Ben thank you good question I
did not go about trying to count the
number of ref references to the right
side in the Bible but you're right they
are all over the place you find them
throughout the Bible and just I'll add a
few to your list here the priests were
anointed on their right ear thumb and
big toe that's in Leviticus 8 Solomon
seated his mother on his right hand in
First Kings 2 the right hand the right
side or the right thigh of a sacrifice
was presented to God as holy and
Leviticus 7 and a variety of other
places and then Jesus places the sheep
on his right side and Matthew chapter 25
what does all this mean well
occasionally right and left were
actually directional notations for North
and South left being North and and right
being South and so Benjamin the son of
my right hand that's what Benjamin means
was actually the southernmost tribe
that's not that's not very common
instead we find that the right hand
really begins to focus on Power and
strength and a beyond that the ability
to help and let me give you a couple of
texts straight from the Bible here
Isaiah 62: eight the Lord has sworn by
his right hand the arm of his power or
the arm of his strength and so we have
just this direct Association the right
hand is his strength and then Psalm 98
verse1 oh sing to the Lord a new song
for he has done marvelous things his
right hand and His holy arm have gained
him the victory this is God's strength
and might and power that is Victorious
Exodus 15:6 says your right hand O Lord
has become become glorious in power your
right hand oh Lord has dashed the enemy
to Pieces so the right hand represents
strength and power and then for us as
humans the right hand also represents
our strength and our work and listen to
these two texts Psalm 109 ver 31 for he
shall stand at the right hand of the
poor to save him from those who condemn
him and then Isaiah 41:13 for I the Lord
your God will hold your right hand
saying to you fear not I will help you
so the right hand is our labor and God
there is helping us in our strength in
our work and then as such with with with
strength and power belonging on the
right side the right side is a place of
authority and honor and so Jesus is
repeatedly described as you mentioned
being seated at the right hand of God
Hebrews 12:2 says we look unto Jesus the
author and finisher of our faith who for
the joy that was set before him endured
the cross despising the name and he sat
down where at the right hand of the
Throne of God and so the right hand
certainly represents Authority and power
and honor and dignity and interestingly
one last reference from Galatians 2:9 we
greet each other with the right hand of
Fellowship this is giving honor to those
who uh who share the faith in Christ
with us amen very great question great
answer Shelly is there a difference
between Father Abraham being the father
of all Nations and the children of
Israel are they one and the
same are all nations and the children of
Israel one and the same Abraham was a
friend of God God revealed his will and
his character to Abraham who believed in
the coming Messiah that he would be
resurrected we see that in Hebrews 11
the faith chapter in John
8:56 Jesus said your for Father Abraham
saw my day and he rejoiced to see my day
he saw it and was glad in Genesis
5156 where Abraham is made righteous by
faith I think this is during this Vision
that he actually saw the coming Messiah
it says in Genesis 15:6 he believed in
the Lord and he counted it or imputed it
to him for righteousness so now let's
look at Abraham as the father of all
Nations Romans 4:11 And1 12 he says he
is the father of all who believe though
they are
uncircumcised that righteousness might
be
imputed to them also he is the father of
all who believe in righteousness by
faith and then it says he's the father
of circumcision to those who not only
are of the circumcision that would be
the national Israel but who also walk in
the steps of Faith which Our Father
Abraham had while still uncircumcised so
it's walking in Christ's footsteps of
righteousness that are going to identify
these children in Genesis 32:28 through3
Israel is a covenant name Jacob had
wrestled with the Lord all night long
and the Lord says to him your name shall
no longer be called Jacob but Israel for
you have struggled with God and with men
and have prevailed so the seed of Jacob
were considered the sons of Israel we
see that in Genesis
42 Israel became a covenant title for
the nation of God's people they were the
firstborn Covenant Son of God according
to Exodus
4:22 and they were merely symbolic or a
type of Jesus who's also referred to as
the firstborn Covenant Son of God so
here's what's interesting and many
people have missed this in Isaiah
49:3 the Messiah is giving a soliloquy
he's talking about himself in Prophecy
and he applies the Covenant name Israel
to himself listen he said to me you are
my servant o Israel in whom I will be
glorified in context of this second
servant's song it is clear that it's
referring to an individual who's
distinct from the nation of Israel who
God goes on to say I will give you as a
covenant to the people to the Gentiles
so while National Israel is referred to
as a Vine John 15 lets us know Jesus
Christ is the true vine
Jesus is also the true Israel who
struggled with men and with God and
prevailed so Israel is a covenant name
used today for all believers from every
nation Romans 96 tells us if you read
Romans 9:6 not all the physical
descendants of Abraham are Heirs of the
promise Galatians 329 tells us that if
you're
Abraham's you are Heirs of the promise
if you're
Abraham's uh spiritual seed Romans 2:28
and 29 tells us that the spiritual
descendants are the ones who are
circumcised in heart that's not
replacement theology it is biblical
Revelation theology the Nations all the
nations are the children of Israel if
they're in Christ amen amen great great
James your second question is there a
physical sanctuary in heaven that Jesus
Christ operates in and this is from
Julie and
Kenya thank you Julie from Kenya that's
a great question a very important one uh
the answer is yes it's a definite yes
there is according to the Bible Moses
going back to Exodus chapter 25 and 26
Moses uh made an Earthly Sanctuary from
a pattern that was shown him in the
heavens and you can read that in Exodus
25:9 and 40 and you know for example um
the candlesticks uh that Moses made uh
were made after a pattern of heaven and
John when he saw uh the temple in heaven
when he saw visions of God's throne in
heaven he saw the seven lamps of fire or
candlesticks representing the seven
spirits of God that Moses patterned the
Earthly Tabernacle uh after you can read
that in Revelation 4:5 now in addition
the New Testament book of Hebrews is
crystal clear on this in Hebrews chapter
8 for example Paul is talking here uh
about all the types all the Earthly
types and how they were a shadow of the
Heavenly and he says now uh Hebrews 8
vers1 now the things that we have spoken
this is the sum we have such a high
priest who said on the right hand
there's the right hand again Daniel on
the right hand of the Throne of the
Majesty in the heavens a minister of the
TR of the sanctuary and the true
Tabernacle which the Lord pitched and
not man and then in verse four he says
for if he he were on Earth he should not
be a priest seeing that there are
priests that offer gifts according to
the law who serve the example of the
shadow of heavenly things he's talking
about the Earthly sanctuary and all of
it was a shadow of the Heavenly things
as Moses would was admonished now he's
quoting from Exodus chapter 25 that we
just referenced as Moses was admonished
of God when he was about to make the
Tabernacle foresees sayith he that thou
makest all things according to the
pattern shown thee in the mount again
Hebrews 4 8: 4 and 5 Hebrews 9 also
talks about the Heavenly Sanctuary a lot
of people get wrapped up in in Paul
talking about the most holy place and
Christ went into the most holy place
there's no such uh support for that idea
in the original Greek hagon hagon it's
hagon it's the holy place or the holies
uh including in in referencing the whole
Sanctuary Paul's burden in Hebrews 8 n
is to get the Jews the Hebrews from the
Earthly type or Shadow to the Heavenly
reality right to what was really being
forecast by that Earthly sanctuary and
of course in the last book of of the New
Testament The Book of Revelation this
Sanctuary language all the way through
it uh John in Revelation 11:19 he saw
the temple opened in heaven he saw the
most holy place he saw the Ark of the
Covenant there in Revelation 11:19 and
again in Revelation 15 5-8 John saw the
temple filled with smoke and no man
could go into the temple and that of
course uh was indic indicative of the
end of probation the close of probation
there's no more mediation and therefore
there's no way that we can get our sins
forgiven after the seven last plagues
begin to fall and probation closes so
the sanctuary is real in heaven it was
typified by the Earthly Sanctuary it is
the place where Christ ministers for us
right now so that we can have our sins
forgiven and blotted out amen great
great
great Daniel number two is it a sin for
a woman to touch or read the Bible
during her monthly period when I was
younger my mom would not allow me to
come up the holy area of the church to
sing or read the Bible and this is from
Sharon in New Zealand all right Sharon
and anybody else who has this question
the short answer is no it is not a sin
there are some religions that may have
prohib prohibitions that are like this
but the Bible does not forbid touching
or reading the Bible at any time of life
regardless of what is going on in the
body regardless of what your past has
been regardless of what your future has
been will be by all means read the Bible
whether you are sick whether you are
missing a limb whether you are tired
read the Bible uh the Bible reading the
Bible is not a ritual all right you can
do it anytime anywhere whoever you are
and you are not excluded by any sort of
thing that is going on in your life
because the Bible the power of the Bible
is not in the cover it's not in the
pages it is not in the ink you cannot
defile the word of God simply by having
dirty hands simply by touching it with
your with your body listen to Psalm
119:1 which says your word I have hidden
in my heart that I might not sin against
you I'm not taking the pages and putting
them in my heart or in my mind I'm
taking the messages I'm taking God's
God's wisdom that he shares with me and
that's what I'm putting in there
Jeremiah 15:6 says your words were found
and I ate them and your word was to me
the joy and rejoicing of my life so once
again we cannot defile the word of God
simply by touching it with that said we
should treat the Bible that we have the
physical item the book with as much care
and respect as we can because it is a
special gift from God it does contain
within it the words of God that then
that then nourish our souls as well so
the Holiness is not in the item it is in
the message from God and we should come
to God even more so with the right
intention of the heart at all times of
our life don't don't let anybody tell
you that you are excluded from coming to
God's word reading it touching it
sharing it memorizing it thinking it and
living by it the condition of our heart
is much more much more important than
whatever is going on in our body amen
great answer amen amen
Shelly this is a a question a lot of
people ask how do you know when the Holy
Spirit is speaking oh that's a great
question and it's vital to understand
let me just hit a few points here first
the holy spirit always speaks in
agreement with the scripture he will
never speak to us in a way that is
contrary to scripture in fact when you
hear the word of God when you're reading
the word word of God you're hearing the
voice of God 2 Timothy 3:16 And1 17 says
that all scripture is inspired by God it
is good for Doctrine which is Mally
means teaching rebuking correcting and
training in righteousness we know second
Peter 1:21 says that holy men of God
wrote as they were moved by the holy
spirit so the Holy Spirit speaks to us
number one through the word of God
number two the holy spirit is a guiding
role in every believer's Life John
16:13 when he the spirit of Truth has
come he will lead you guide you into all
truth when you open the word of God pray
for the Holy Spirit to give you
discernment because number three the
holy spirit gives us ability to
understand divide truths 1 Corinthians
2:12 through3 14 14 says These Are
Spiritual words they are spiritually
discerned you have to have the guidance
of the holy spirit so do you want to
hear his voice get into the word the
more time you spend in the word the word
the more you will discern the spirit's
leading regular Bible study and I know
when I first started listening for the
Lord he gave me just a few words and
then say look it up and I would go and
find a scripture to support it the Holy
Spirit number four leads us to
repentance by speaking to our hearts
John 168 he helps us to recognize our
sin he can fixs the world of sin and
righteousness and judgment so anytime we
say it's our conscience but when you
recognize that something's impressing
upon your mind this is wrong don't
neglect the spirit of the Lord he's
speaking to amen number five to be a
child of God you must be led by the
spirit Romans 8:14 says as many as are
led by the spirit of God these are the
sons of God now number six walk by the
spirit Galatians 5 16- 18 Paul says I
say walk by the spirit you won't gratify
the desires of the flesh because the
flesh desires things that are contrary
to the spirit the spirit desires things
that are contrary to the flesh so let me
give you just a couple of points Psalm
46:10 God says be still and know that I
am God it takes intentional listening we
need to if you think God is speaking to
you the Holy Spirit won't speak against
the word but seek Godly counsel there is
wisdom in a multitude of counselors what
wait for the peace of God that
transcends all understanding if you feel
like God is leading you to do something
after you've sought people wait and make
sure you've got that peace and then look
for God to open and close doors of
opportunity amen thank you amen just
want to take just uh probably about 15
seconds and go over the contacts again
how you can contact 3abn with your
questions if you want to text them it's
3975 if you would like to email them
Bible QA
3abn.org
question number three yes sir and this
came in this same question came in from
from two people that's Darnell in
Virginia and Fay in Arkansas how can I
answer a mother who has had an abortion
and now has turned her life around will
she see her baby again in heaven will
aborted babies be in
heaven such an important and sensitive
question both those questions you know
only God himself knows who will be in
heaven and that goes for everyone um and
again only God knows who will be in
heaven yet we can have much assurance
that God will save our children
especially The Unborn there there are
there is a large church that believes
that if you're not baptized at infant
you have no chance of going to heaven
but that's not actually what the Bible
teaches Jesus Christ's righteousness
covers Us and can even cover The Unborn
he was baptized for those who couldn't
be baptized like the thief on the cross
so a mother who's turned her life around
can claim the promises of God's word
that she will see her baby in heaven and
that she will be reunited uh and will
raise up that little one and God knows
every baby and whether or not they can
be saved in heaven even though they were
aborted and in his wisdom God will have
every child that can be in heaven and
respond to his grace and love there now
the Bible says in Isaiah 49:2 24-25
listen to these verses they're just
beautiful shall the prey be taken from
the mighty or the lawful captive
delivered but thus sayith the Lord even
the captives of of the mighty shall be
taken away and the prey of the terrible
shall be delivered for I will contend
with him that contends with thee and I
will save thy children excuse me just a
powerful promise and I claim this uh you
can claim this for your children I claim
this for my children you can claim this
for those children that you lost
selfishly in a time in your life when
you weren't following God here's some
more bible promises that you can claim
for your aborted child Jeremiah 31:15
to17 thus sayith the Lord a voice was
heard in rahen lamentation and bitter
weeping Rachel weeping for her children
refused to be comforted for her children
because they not thus sayth the Lord
refrain from thy voice from weeping and
thine eyes from tears for thy Work shall
be rewarded says the Lord and they shall
come again from the land of the enemy
and if there's any land that's the land
of the enemy it's death and God is going
to overthrow death It's the final enemy
that's going to be destroyed they shall
come again from the land of the enemy
and there is hope in thine end says the
Lord that thy children shall come again
to their own border you know this is a
hope that all of us have as Believers we
have them for our children that are
alive uh that were born and we have them
we can have them also for those that
were unborn uh when we made stupid
mistakes and God can redeem that uh from
the death God can redeem that mistake
that we've made uh for that child who
from conception had life and God knows
the heart of that child if that heart
can be in heaven and again we need to
trust God for that but we need to claim
these promises um for those unborn
children amen
it is a sensitive area we hear about it
daily in the in the
news uh D
Daniel your third question should be
should we be washing dishes at church on
Sabbath after lunch I don't do dishes on
Sabbath at home but wait until the
Sabbath is over please
advise
uh what do you say on that well I don't
know that can advise you but let's at
least look at what God's word says and
let the Holy Spirit impress our hearts
you know based upon the origin of the
Sabbath and the Garden of Eden and what
God has to say in the fourth Commandment
I believe the Sabbath is holier than you
and I could ever imagine and we may have
convictions that that God has led us to
on our own but dealing with other people
you know that in that requires some tact
and gentleness and kindness that the
holy spirit will move us toward uh
remember the Sabbath day to keep holy
it's to be holy six days you shall labor
do all your works so things that we
should anything we can put aside uh
anything that we can prepare in advance
is what we ought to do but the seventh
day is the Sabbath of the Lord your God
in it you shall do no work does that
mean I can't tie my shoes or my
daughter's shoes as she's learning to
tie that I mean that that may be labor
is that labor that might make a
dangerous situation what about cleaning
up spaghetti sauce that spills on the
floor or water that spills that could
make the floor warped and Soggy and that
could create a dangerous situation
can I change a baby's diaper can I can I
wash my dog who rolled in something
nasty outside and it's now running
through the house rubbing it on guests
uh clothing and on the couch uh you know
can can I do that if I can't do dishes
can I at least carry my dish to the sink
and this line of reasoning uh we it's
kind of an awful way to start thinking
about the Sabbath it's kind of what led
to the Pharisees regulations and not
that we shouldn't care about what we do
when we start to say well I draw the
line here
and all of a sudden somebody else thinks
that I'm completely out of God's will
because they drew the line right there
instead and so really we we want to
instead of of looking at the Sabbath
from terms of prohibition Behavior what
is it we can't do say Lord you've told
us that the Sabbath is intended to be a
blessing for us and a gift for us so I
want to look at it instead this way not
to say I'm I'm not going to be trying to
hear God say no don't don't do that do
this and instead but I want to be
resonating in my life what will bring me
closer to God on the Sabbath what will
fulfill the will of God for me what will
bring glory to God today what will unite
my family in Christian service what will
open our hearts to understand and
receive God's blessings even more and so
what will what will help us to bring
lasting blessings and so when we start
there we will find that the Sabbath
becomes filled with blessings I know
that I personally live in a home with
seven people and if we have guests in
the home then uh you know if we don't do
the dishes from breakfast there won't be
any dishes for lunch and and that could
then result in an unsanitary and
unhealthful situation uh you know and so
somebody might say well you should fast
at that time well I don't think that
that's why God would have told the
Israelites to collect a double portion
of food on Friday
uh it was was to carry them through to
the Sabbath as well Jesus tells us in
Luke 14:5 that there are some tasks that
must be done on the Sabbath he's talking
about animals here there are some things
that must be done to carry on life and
he tells us in Mark 2:27 that the
Sabbath was made for man as a gift as a
blessing and not man for the Sabbath so
I'm not going to draw any sort of line
for you but I'm going to say go back to
that that commandment go back to the
Holy Spirit say Lord convict me and as I
have those convictions in my heart
before you help me then to deal gently
and kindly and tactfully with others who
may draw the line in a different place
you know we we don't want to certainly
squelch somebody else or or rip them up
by the roots because of the way that
that we enforce rules that that that God
has put Upon Our conscience but by all
means uh be obedient to the to your
conscience to what God has has asked you
to do from his word amen amen wow very
good Shelly mhm your third question does
the bible tell us when the thief on the
cross died we know his legs were broken
but I don't think it says he actually
died the same day that Jesus died well
let's look at that we find the the story
first in Luke 23 well not first but Luke
39-43 where the thief on the cross
they're hurling insults at Jesus and
this one wakes up and says
you know this man doesn't deserve it and
he asked Jesus to remember him when he
comes into his kingdom do you know Roman
crucifixion was brutal and it was
essentially death by asphixiation what
do I mean they hung them on the cross
they sometimes tied or nailed them to
this Beam on the cross and the way that
the body hung they could not breathe and
so they put this little shelf down there
for their feet and the crucified ones
who were out in the Heat and doing they
would push up to try to get a breath and
it was very painful to push up but they
would push up just so that they could
get a breath and finally when they did
not have the physical strength to push
up they died by asphixiation they could
not breathe so to hasten death they
sometimes broke the legs of the victims
listen to John
31-34 I'm reading from the
Amplified John 19 here we have this
again the crucifixion of Jesus since it
was the day of preparation in order to
prevent the bodies from hanging on the
cross on the Sabbath so this is what
they're preventing they don't want those
bodies to still be on the cross on the
Sabbath day for that Sabbath was very
solemn and important when the Jews
requested pilot to have the legs broken
and the bodies taken away so the
soldiers came broke the legs of the
first one and of the other who had been
crucified with him with Jesus but when
they came to Jesus saw that he was
already dead they did not break his
slakes but one of the soldiers pierced
his side with a spear and immediately
blood and water ran out the exact time
of death for the thief on the cross is
not recorded but because his leg were
broken he could not have been breathed
and he was his body was removed from the
cross before Sabbath hours began so he
died shortly after
Jesus okay
amen James your fourth question yes sir
on the cross Jesus prayed father forgive
them for they know not what they do was
that for the priest rulers pilot or the
crowd
we are told that those who crucified him
will see him come in glory was the
soldier forgiven who commanded surely he
was the son of God what about the thief
who unselfishly though ignorantly asked
Jesus save yourself and us was the
requested forgiveness for the taunting
crowd or the disillusion cowering
disciples and this is from a viewer in
Maryland such an important question you
know forgiveness is a two-way street uh
first of all it comes to us from God and
it comes by God's grace at Titus chap
2:1 says for the grace of God that
brings salvation has appeared unto all
men um and so this is what Jesus was
communicating on the cross on calvary's
Cross he was communicating a forgiveness
that comes to every single person not
just the select few not just his
disciples or the thief that believed he
was communicating forgiveness for all of
those even those who were Cru CR ifying
him because he was dying for the sins of
the world Isaiah 53 makes this plain
when it says beginning in verse 11 he
shall see the travail of his soul and
shall be satisfied by his knowledge
shall my righteous servant justify many
for he shall bear their iniquities
therefore I will divide him a portion
with the great and he shall divide the
spoil with the strong because he has
poured out his soul unto death and he
was numbered with the transgressors he
bear the sin of many and made
intercession for the transgressors so
Jesus Christ is fulfilling this prophecy
in Isaiah 53 specifically verse 12 where
it says he made intercession for the
transgressors now this last sentence is
what happened at the cross Jesus made
intercession for all of the
transgressors not just a few again
forgiveness is a two-way street for
example God calls Christians to turn the
other cheek and to go the extra mile and
this calls for the Same Spirit of
forgiveness that Jesus exemplified At
The Cross and throughout his entire life
now as a
many people accepted Christ's
forgiveness we're going to say that the
the people that heard those words many
of them later on um became forgiven and
their lives were healed and cleansed
from guilt and shame and evil they
actually accepted Christ so for them
Christ's prayer was answered we're told
that thousands uh of Jews and Priests
included uh responded to the holy
spirit's conviction on the day of
Pentecost yet for many of the priests
and rulers and people the Forgiveness of
Christ prayer was never accepted and
never acted upon that's the two-way
street you know Christ can pour out his
grace upon us but if we don't receive
that Grace if we don't respond to that
Grace we will never actually be forgiven
in our personal subjective experience
have you ever forgiven someone who
refused to accept or acknowledge your
forgiveness so you can forgive but that
doesn't mean a person is Forgiven and
this is what God deals with all the time
the unmar unmerited favor of of God Goes
Forth to every person on planet Earth
but not all accept it um the other thief
the taunting crowd we don't know for
sure the disillusion the crying
disciples yes indeed they accepted
Christ they were forgiven by Grace
praise God and uh and so God today we
can right now we can be forgiven and and
none of us should hesitate to accept the
love and the grace of God to be forgiven
to accept that forgiveness to embrace
the faith of Jesus dying on the cross
for us personally in individually Jesus
loves you he loves and died for you and
he has forgiven you by his death and he
wants you to accept to embrace that
forgiveness profit you on calvary's
Cross um and he wants you to allow that
forgiveness to transform your life so
that you live for him amen amen well
stated
Daniel I understand being saved by the
blood of Jesus is most important but I
don't hear or see about the healing of
the sick or casting out of demons Jesus
did it and so did the disciples why
don't we do this has this changed and
this is from
Nick all right Nick this is an important
question especially as we do look
through the New Testament the times of
Jesus and the apostles and we do see
these activities and we wonder is that
supposed to be going on in the church
today so let's let's look at what Jesus
did because Jesus was a true medical
missionary which means he met the
physical needs of the people and then he
gave to them also the bread of life and
we're going to look at Matthew 4 2 veres
verse 23 and 24 says and Jesus went
about all Galilee this is the beginning
of his ministry describing what he did
teaching in their synagogues preaching
the gospel of the Kingdom all right so
you got sharing of the word and healing
all kinds of sickness and all kinds of
disease among the people then his Fame
went throughout all Syria and they
brought to him all sick people who were
Afflicted with various diseases and
torments and those who were
demon-possessed epileptics and
paralytics and he healed them so we have
this Unity of work here preaching
healing and casting out the devil
casting out Satan and the demons now
Jesus not only did this he entrusted
this power he empowered his disciples to
work in the same way he had Mark 3: 14
and 15 we'll find this in other places
too where Jesus sends out the 12
disciples says he appointed 12 that they
might with him and that they he might
send them out to preach to have power to
heal sicknesses and to cast out demons
all three of those United as a single
Ministry preaching healing casting out
demons now this wasn't just uh limited
to the 12 in Luke chapter 10 Jesus also
sends out 70 and he gives them the same
Authority the same power now it's not
within them they don't have the power to
do those things it's God's power now
they come back and they're rejoicing
that even demons submitted to them and
Jesus says I saw Satan we're we're in
Luke 10 verse Verse 18 Jesus said to
them I saw Satan fall like lightning
from Heaven behold I give you authority
to trample on serpents and scorpions
with this symbolic element here The
Serpent and Scorpion representing
deception and res representing uh the
deceptive evil power of Satan and over
all the powers of the enemy and nothing
shall by any means hurt you okay so uh
you have the 70 now carrying out this
same Mission we get to the end of of
Mark chap 6 of Mark 16: 15 to 18 and
this is Mark's account of the Great
Commission this is Jesus sending out his
instructions to his church to his
Believers and does the United effort of
preaching healing and casting out demons
end at the end of the Jesus ministry
when he ascends to Heaven Jesus said to
them go into all the world and preach
the gospel there's the first part to
every creature he who believes and is
baptized will be saved but he who does
not believe will be condemned and these
signs will follow those who believe in
my name they will cast out demons
there's that part right there they will
speak with new tongues they will take up
serpents this is not physical serpents
it's representing the deceptive
destructive power of Satan and they will
and if they drink anything deadly it
will by no means hurt them they will lay
hands on the sick and they will recover
three parts of this this message full
healing not just thoughts but of of our
full self and in the words of Jesus
Matthew 19:6 what God has joined
together let no man separate so did
demon possession end when Jesus returned
to Heaven no and neither did the force
of his Great Commission how long is the
preaching of the Gospel to to last well
this Gospel of the Kingdom will be
preached to All Nations as a witness to
all people and then the end will come
keep on preaching this gospel so Jesus
does not send us out to work without
also giving us the power to do the work
which he commands the hungry still need
to be fed the poor still need to be
helped those possessed by evil spirits
still need to hear the voice of God
spoken to them through us now listen
carefully I am not telling you what to
do nor am I telling you how to do it but
I am affir affirming that healing and
casting out of demons are still a
combined part of the prophetic mission
that God wants his people to do we need
to avoid fanaticism on either side the
fanaticism that says there's no healings
there's no casting out of spirits and on
the other hand there's the fanaticism of
these highly emotionalized processes
that don't go according to God's word
and not his will or healing processes
that are not according to God's means
God has a way of healing and then
there's the fanaticism of quick fixes
that we can snap change somebody on our
own true healing true casting out the
works of the devil always restores
obedience obedience to God's law both
his moral law and the physical laws that
help strengthen our our health in our
body um setting captives free happens by
God's work by his power and his power
alone and no power can do it other than
him we are not the healers God is amen
amen very good that's close to preaching
there
amen Shelly yes 1 Corinthians
15:53 for this corruptible must put on
incorruption and this Mortal must put on
immortality this confuses me it says
that we are Immortal but if we become
immortal is our immorality
immortality conditional later it
mentions the Tree of Life of which we
shall eat of are we only Immortal if we
eat of the Tree of Life in Revelation
2:7 that would make us not really
Immortal because we would have to eat of
the tree to maintain life I just don't
know what to think next okay I think
that uh let's just stick to the
scripture here I want to ask and answer
two questions what was God's intended
purpose for the Tree of Life In The
Garden was it to provide
immortality and then the second question
can the gift of everlasting life eternal
life
immortality can that gift once be
bestowed by Christ be uh and and it's
going to be bestowed on the people who
are in Christ who are walking in loyal
obedience to his Commandments motivated
by love can that be reversed once we've
received the gift so let's look at this
the Bible tells us in 1 Timothy 6:16 God
alone has
immortality God's immortality is
inherent it is not a gift from anyone it
was not borrowed his life is underived
so God's mortality is inherent in humans
were not
created Immortal we find
1600 references to the human soul and it
never once talks about being Immortal so
when Adam and Eve were
created they were given access to every
every tree in the garden except one the
tree of the knowledge of Good and Evil
and they needed access to the tree of
life for continued life let's look at
Genesis well it's in Genesis to that the
the Garden of Eden the tree
represented the ongoing life that God
intended it was his lifegiving provision
and Power
but what was God's intended purpose of
the tree and life was that to give
immortality no Adam and Eve had access
to the Tree of Life from the fall and it
was they were still mortal human beings
when when it demanded continual access
to have a life so in Genesis 3 after the
fall God lovingly protected them he
prohibited them from accessing the tree
of life because he didn't want them to
continually reach and eat from that and
to continue to live in a state of sin so
God's Paradise his Garden of Eden his
plan is
disrupted and what Revelation shows us
is the Prophecies of God restoring the
Garden of Eden he is recreating the
Earth to be the creation it was intended
in revelation 22 1-2 John is shown the
New Jerusalem the Throne of God in the
lamb Eden is restored and there is the
tree of life it's interesting it says in
the middle of its Street and on either
side of the river was the Tree of Life
which bore 12 fruits each tree yielding
its fruit each month now First
Corinthians Ians 15 let's back up verse
52-54 1 Corinthians 15
52-54 at the last trumpet the
resurrection of Life those who are dead
in Christ will come forward they're
changed because they are given the gift
of immortality this differs from God
it's a gift it's not inherent but listen
to what verse 54 says when this corble
has put on incorruption and this Mortal
has put on immortality then shall be
brought to pass the saying that is
written death is swallowed up in Victory
so can the gift of eternal life for
those who are in Christ be reversed once
we've been given that gift there's
nothing in Scripture that suggests that
by definition
immortality means never dying or
decaying
God will never allow sin to rise again
Nam 1:9 so we always see everlasting
life Immortal Life is is granted by
Union with Christ Jesus so is it
conditional it's conditional on our
Union with Christ but what happens is we
are given the right when God restores
everything Revelation 27 says to those
who are victorious I will give the right
to eat from the Tree of Life which is in
the paradise of God so scripture does
not explicitly State the requirement to
eat from the Tree of Life for continued
immortality it is part of the Abundant
Life that we will experience in the New
Jerusalem great answer let's take a
quick break we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3 ABN Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
5 that's
6182280065 he's going to
restore all things in heaven amen James
amen amen oh I just wanted to uh comment
on something that Shelley said earlier
it was something that Dan touched Daniel
touched on too in a previous Q&A that we
did and that was uh knowing how to hear
the voice of God and I really
appreciated that the the explanation you
know the more we study God's word the
clearer God's voice uh becomes to us and
that happened to me this morning I was
really agonizing over something
and the word of God came and make it
Crystal Clear what I needed to do and I
just love that you know the Holy Spirit
inspires God's word and so just en just
wanted to thank Shelly and Daniel
earlier and just encourage our viewers
get into the word of God and you'll be
able to discern God's voice amen amen I
just want to share this real quick call
to me and I will answer you and show you
Great and Mighty things which you do not
know God bless you today this has been a
wonderful time I hope some of your
questions have been answered God God
bless bye-bye
[Music]